400 north capital street northwest suite
650 washington dc
2001
or call us at area code 765-464-3080
next in april of 1993 encore book notes
interview with marshall de bruyl who
wrote sword of jacinto a life of sam
houston it's a biography of the once
president of texas and u.s senator it's
about an hour
marshall de bruyne author of sword of
san jacinto a life of sam houston
what's the sword of san jacinto well it
uh
the sword is recurring theme in the book
he uh of course he carried this sword uh
in the into the battle held it up as he
led the men across the plain down there
outside what is now houston texas
and then later
he presented it to the people of texas
when he became president of texas and
turned himself into a man of from from
war to peace in front of the texas
congress it was a separate republic then
and then later he left it to his son
and it's still in the family actually
and he left it to his son but to be
drawn only in the defense of liberty as
he said in the will who was sam houston
sam you mean not the son but the older
man
he was a
i think the main thing he was this great
national figure that's what one has to
keep in mind that he was this
extraordinary virginian he was born in
the in the 18th century he was one of
those great 18th century virginians
but who
of course
did his great work and achieved his
great fame much farther afield than
those who went to philadelphia or
washington
and
he had two great political careers one
in tennessee where he was
an attorney general
major general of the militia a two-term
congressman and then governor of
tennessee
all before he was 34 years old and then
uh had another career
of course as we all know in texas and in
the united states senate let me ask you
about this cover where does this
is this a painting the painting i'm uh
an artist it was painted here in
washington when houston was uh in the
united states senate in 1846
he was 53 years old as you can see from
the picture he was given to these
rather colorful costumes and flamboyant
attire and uh but this was a man named
head the painter who was a who was a
sort of court painter here in washington
who made the decision to put it on the
cover
uh the art director at random house that
we went back and forth with this because
there were so many choices and finally
this young man who's the art director's
publishing house decided that he would
just take on this and do it himself and
and
as you can imagine when these things are
done there's a lot of committee thing
goes on and finally but as always
there's no democracy in the arts and so
i think this man decided young man
decided i will do this and then he
produced what i think is a very
beautiful book actually
let's go right to the heart in the
middle of the book to the texas
revolution
what was it
well it started of course the beginning
of the texas revolution was when texas
or
which one was the province of tejasi
coaguila which was a province of mexico
and when
mexico gained its independence from
spain the trouble began really right
there but this area called texas or
tejas was not inhabited there weren't
very many people there so the mexican
government had a policy of encouraging
immigration from the united states
so stephen austin or his father moses
austin began this
they've got this enormous land grant in
texas of hundreds of thousands of acres
millions of acres really and
then
recruited colonists to come down there
and the seeds were sown then for really
for revolution because you ran head-on
into an autocratic government of mexico
and these people who were basically
libertarians from the from the north and
so the trouble began in the 1820s when
the first colonists arrived and then
when mexico became more and more
despotic
under a
succession of people but chiefly antonio
lopez de santa anna when he became
president a dictator of mexico and he
decided that
this colonization should stop from the
north and uh he was going to tighten up
the screws on these colonists who were
causing him some trouble
and
but of course these people were from
america were going to put up with it and
uh so one thing led to another and then
the whole situation rapidly unraveled
and houston arrived there in 1832
right where in uh
in a place called nacogdoches texas and
from uh
from the arkansas territory where he was
living and so he had gone down there in
december of 1832 he crossed the red
river into texas
and then went on to nacogdoches and then
joined up with stephen austin's colony
in a place called san felipe de austin
and
austin's headquarters were and
was given his land grant
and set up a law practice in texas
and then later when the
revolution was heating up austin had
gone to mexico to negotiate with santa
ana
over more civil rights for
liberties for the
anglo settlers of texas
and then austin was thrown into prison
he's been he's been over two years in
the mexican jail
so uh when he came back then the
revolution was really
the
the course had started then to have a
rebel to have a revolute full-scale war
against mexico
and
so sam was there and since he had all
this military experience he was made
commander-in-chief of the texas army
and began to organize an army and tried
to put it together this was in the late
of 1835.
the revolution was actually very short
it was only a few months and
i'm pushing it was the battle of sanchez
and that was only 18 minutes so they
compressed everything pretty much to for
their independence how many people lived
in texas in 1835 probably around 35 000
or so 30 to 35 000 people it was very
small and uh including the uh
the slaves about a quarter of those were
black slaves that the colonists had
brought in the mexican nationals who
lived there and then the anglo-saddlers
so it couldn't be more than 35 000
people it's a small group why had sam
houston gone to
texas in the first place well there's
there are several theories uh
americans of course as you know love
conspiracy theories and so of course the
one theory is that he was dispatched by
andrew jackson to separate texas from
mexico because see jackson always
assumed that texas was had been part of
the louisiana purchase and it belonged
to the united states in any event
and the border did not it would extend
he thought extended all the way to the
rio grande or the nueces really and then
but
and it was really american territory
but uh as one historian pointed out
lorena friend
who had written another biography of
houston years ago and her answer all
this was why i was houston in texas it
was to make a living and i think it's
like so many people went to texas you
know to
for fame and fortune and he had you know
his whole political career collapsed in
america with the collect with the
dissolution of the first marriage and
the great scandal
so he had no future really left in
tennessee or even in arkansas for that
matter where he had moved
so his uh his future lay in somewhere
else and texas was the place to go and
many people think still is of course and
so he uh
removed there and and set up a law
practice
and uh and and was given this great
grant of land by austin to be in the
austin colony you see so basically it
was for land and to make a living that's
why he was there originally
and
houston texas
austin texas dallas texas
lubbock texas
waco texas they all named after
people well austin of course named after
stephen austin who was who is rightly
called the father of texas houston you
know people say he was the father of
texas he was actually the father of
texas independence austin is the is the
man who got the colonists there and is
considered really the father of texas so
the city of austin is named after him
houston named after um
sam it was a it was a place called
harrisburg when it was burned during the
revolution and then when they rebuilt
this new town they laid it out they
named it after the victorious general
sam houston about dallas
dallas is uh
i didn't find the name dallas in the
book well it didn't really exist at the
time i mean dallas is a 20th century
intervention with apologies to my
friends in dallas but this basically a
20th century invention and uh there was
a small settlement there houston
actually went there and he was
campaigning and for governor of texas
and for
uh at the time in the 1840s it was it
was it was there of course it was across
uh headwaters of the river this was a
little fort there
in those days go back to the uh the
revolution the the the sword of san
jacinto the battle of san jacinto
why is that such a big deal
well it uh when houston
he had retreated before the mexican army
across texas and that's that's another
subject of great dispute was he really
running or was it was it a strategic
retreat my
feeling is of course it was a strategic
retreat he was drawing santa ana farther
and farther into
what was anglo texas that's where all
the people were was in east texas
so the whole he ended uh it ended up on
this place called buffalo bayou just
outside the present day houston
and there uh with his back to the water
he decided to attack the mexican army
which outnumbered him two to one
and so on the afternoon of april 21st
of 1836
uh they stormed across that field there
and in just 18 minutes conquered the
mexican army
and it's it's important as jackson said
it was a much more it was much greater
victory than jackson's own victory at
new orleans which of course it was
what it did was to
give texas to
eventually to the united states
annexation was later of course
and it led directly
to
the expansion all the way to the west
coast i mean all are part of six states
were the results of this this great
battle you see so it was a it was
one of the great battles in history
who tell us what santa who santa anna
was and what he was like well he was a
he was a self-style he called himself
the napoleon of the west and uh
and he had indeed had great successes in
in the million as a soldier in mexico
against
the spanish forces for the the
revolution against spain and then his
march across texas was one victory after
another
and uh granted that they were
he won the battles and of course he shot
everybody afterward there was no quarter
really when he
uh the great calamity at the alamo after
they had surrendered and he you know
assassinated or executed people who had
a few survivors including david crockett
and then a few weeks later at this place
called goliad texas when they overran
james fannin and his his men at goliad
they actually they marched 342 people
out and men out and executed them there
and just shot them down in cold blood
so he was a bloodthirsty man actually
can we go back to the alamo yeah sure
what was the story and when when did it
happen
it happened in march of 1836 and houston
had uh had sent james bowie and
bonham james bonham there
to tell them to to
blow up the place and abandon the alamo
what is it first where is it it's it's
in the it's in a it's a one of the in
san antonio texas there are five
missions and uh the alamo was one of
those missions that the
mexican church had established five
missions for
for pacification of the indians and to
assimilate the indian tribes and this
was just one of those missions
it was it actually had been closed down
it was in ruins really and it was a
small fort built around it and
so the texas texans had decided to
fortify this place and to hold it
against the
advancing mexican troops
but houston had told them to get out
there then blow it up and bring the
available ammunition and horses and
whatever and join his army in the east
he was trying to organize a full
full-scale army you see well they got to
the alamo and travis and
they decided that they would hold it you
see that they would defend it against
the mexicans which was folly of course
and it led to this enormous terrible
disaster you see
and uh
houston has always
there's always been great controversy
about that too did he really tell them
to uh to go there and blow it up i'm
convinced that indeed he did i read the
letters and things of course that he did
do this and then he also told fannin to
get out of the mission at goliad that
was another mission about 80 miles away
to get out of there and join him
and that way they would have had the 180
men who killed at the alamo and the 340
men killed at uh
goliad that's quite the number of
able-bodied men shot down you see so
houston would have had that force and
plus their ammunition and their
armaments
within for his army but of course it was
lost to him because of this folly of
these two men did you go back to san
jacinto
which houston won against santa hanna
what did he what did he do with santa
ana after the he's a mexican president
mexican president dictator and the the
santa anna uh there's there are all
these other stories they're wonderful
legends about all of this of course and
and some of them
thank god they're true it makes a more
interesting book he uh when they
charged across the field that afternoon
of april 21st 1836 santa ana was having
us he was in his
the silken tent that he carried with him
lived in some luxury actually
and he was in the tent and the story is
that he was with his uh uh
wilding away the afternoon with his
mystery it's the famous yellow rose of
texas and now whether or not this is a
true story no it's a wonderful story
certainly he was in the tent there are
other stories that
texans had sent her there to seduce you
know like delilah and samson uh whether
or not that's true i'm not certain but
anyway it's a good good tale and uh
anyway uh
suddenly i ran out of his tent and
jumped on the horse and escaped in the
middle of all of this abandoned his men
and headed across the prairies there
outside on the plain of san jacinto
and then found some clothing in the
farmhouse and changed his put civilian
clothes on over his uniform and then the
next day
uh there's a scouting party a texas
scouting party uh discovered this
sort of short
mexican soldier uh hobbling across the
plains and uh and picked him up and
were trying to make him walk back to the
camp and in santa ana
and his own uh his autobiography he said
he couldn't do it he was just too worn
out from all of this and so they
threatened to shoot him and then a young
enlisted man said he could ride on the
back of his horse they put him up behind
this enlisted man
and they went back into the camp
still not knowing that they had found
the mexican president this was santa ana
until the mexican troops all started
shouting el president el presidente and
then they realized that they had the
santa ana so he took him to houston who
would of course have been wounded in the
bottle and was lying on his blanket
under a tree
and santa ana
always arrogant said
he is born to no common destiny the
conqueror of the napoleon of the west
and that was the first thing he said to
houston as he's lying there wounded on
his blanket how badly was sam houston he
was shot through the ankle and and very
seriously actually and
so much so that he had to be taken to
new orleans for medical treatment
but then santa ana the the thing was to
keep him alive as a great bargaining
chip
and uh
then then he did agree that there was
another mexican army not far away you
see the thing was to get this army to
to withdraw from texas
and then which santana dispatched to
messengers and they did withdraw from
texas or head back toward mexico
one of the more
difficult things to understand was
eventually
santa anna was freed and sent to
washington yes
well the thing was the idea was uh
to
use as long as he was alive
they could use him as a bargaining chip
really with the mexicans to to withdraw
from texas and that worked then the
other thing was that the plan eventually
was they would return him to mexico and
he would he was so mischievous and and
he was this would help destabilize the
government and so texas would not be
threatened from that quarter again which
basically worked he did go back
live to fight another day he was he was
became
he was in and out of mexican politics
until he was a very very old man and was
president i think a dozen times or
something like that after this
but the irony was when they sent him
north
uh this butcher really who had been so
vilified and excoriated in the american
press
uh they he
went north on the steamboat up the
mississippi then the ohio then they had
to at louisville
the the river was blocked by ice and so
they had to take him in a carriage then
they went back down the river to
louisville and got him a carriage and
went across country to washington middle
of the winter in the middle of winter
and houston had given him a great wool
cloak to wear
and because he knew that he'd be cold in
the north and
so uh and santa ana named the cloak sam
and i always refer thanked him every day
when he was here in washington freezing
in the winter of
1837
and uh
so then he stayed here for quite a while
and and and
jackson had a dinner frame with all the
cabinet assembled at the white house
andrew jackson andrew jackson had had
the mexican butcher dictator to the
white house and
then finally even they they got tired of
him even here i mean i think the
attention span after it's visiting
celebrities are fine but it's time to
send him home and so they sent him in uh
on the american gun battleship really
the equivalent of a battleship in those
days to mexico and he landed at veracruz
and
uh after a
long period began to meddle in the
affairs of mexico again of course is
there any way to relate the idea of
santa ana coming to this town and being
you know entertained by the president to
today i mean would it be like saddam
hussein coming here
roughly yeah i think that that's a good
analogy actually you know the fact that
here suddenly he's uh being entertained
i remember once when i years ago
standing outside the waldorf in new york
watching hirohito come out and i
remember when i was a little boy during
the war thinking that would this ever
have been possible remember this man of
course and here we were all standing in
park avenue in the middle of park avenue
to watch the japanese emperor come out
of the waldorf astoria
and
so perhaps it's the same kind of thing
that you these today's
enemies are tomorrow's tomorrow's
friends
you've got some photographs in here and
i i want to see if i can find some uh
to show the audience
but before i do
if sam houston were sitting here
what would we be seeing what kind of a
person would he have been well i think
you'd be seeing this uh well there's
people throw this expression larger than
life around quite a bit you know and i
think you'd be seeing uh this is the
painting by thomas sully
the famous american painter and you know
the great story some woman in austin in
nashville tennessee once said that two
types of people were drawn to houston
all his life women and artists
and so houston uh loved to be painted
left to be photographed
this is a miniature of houston as a
young congressman here in the in
washington
and uh
but that's the earliest uh likeness of
him actually
that was done here when he was in the
congress
about 1823. a lot about him was drinking
well he was a heavy drinker it was a
serious problem and i'm not convinced
his presumably his third wife sobered
him up but i'm not convinced of that as
i say in the book he uh
he drank bitters which i looked looked
all this up to see you know we all know
i mean bitter is whatever and it's 80
it's 80 proof it's it's equivalent of
bourbon really the stuff that he drank
and that's of sam as a as a senator you
know late in life
and did he drink all his life
i think he did
up well up until maybe the last 10 years
when he uh because he had become a sort
of darling of the temperance movement
you know that was one of those things
that
swept the country for a while and uh
and he made speeches and uh in behalf of
temperance later but that was when he
was in his uh oh he was 60 years old by
that time but he had he had certainly
had drunk up till till in
late 50s certainly it seems to me how
old was he when he died he was 70
exactly 18.
he died in huntsville texas in this uh
rather eccentric house that they had
rented they had no money they had land
there's like most southern nursery
they're land poor and
he uh they'd gone back there after he
was deposed from the governorship of
texas had moved back to huntsville a
place that he had liked and where they
had lots of property
but they rented it was a rented house
this house called the steamboat house
and this rather strange looking
building that looks like a mississippi
river boat really and
this eccentric man that built it and
used it appealed to sam and so he uh
rented it and he and margaret and their
children were living in the house when
he died i want to ask you about all the
jobs he had in government and all of his
wives but first i want to ask you about
yourself
you're listed in here is living in north
carolina half the time yeah i go well
somebody said i lived a third of the
time in north carolina a third of the
time in the interstate and i think third
of the time in the research libraries
and
so i've been i have a of our family
house in asheville north just outside
asheville north carolina so i'm living
there most of the time i show the
audience who you dedicate this book to
uh there are
three different people exactly yes uh
who's gloria jones glory jones is the
widow of james jones the great american
novelist who wrote from here to eternity
and thin red line and uh
books such books as that and gloria's my
great friend from
east hampton we actually worked together
once a double day she was a she was an
editor also
and
so gloria had
was the one who said to me marshall when
are you going to write your book on sam
houston we were actually we're driving
down the long island expressway in new
york and i was talking about this man
and i had i guess bored her to death
with and she finally said me why don't
you write this book and uh
and she actually introduced me to my
editor at random house bob loomis
and who has deemed a brutal blessing
that's my old decision i'm the youngest
of nine children and this she's the
oldest and
she gave me her house in north carolina
on this lake lake lure in north carolina
and she said to me
she thought i was being a bit dilatory
about it and one day she just loaded me
up and took me down on my computer and
word processor and notes and said now
here you are and
almost locked me in the house and spent
the next two years so of course she was
uh
and also she's been a great help to me
all my life of course being the oldest
child and i've been the youngest child
still alive oh yes indeed all nine still
alive yes absolutely what's the age
range from uh 72 to mid 50s yeah
where'd you all grow up we grew up in in
malcolm county north carolina
what'd your mom and dad do
my mother was a housewife my father was
uh
i think his greatest achievement was he
was a
great uh labor organizer for the flcio
and that's but then he went on the other
side management in working for an
electrical construction company but but
for years and years he was very much
involved in the labor movement in
america where did you go to school i
went to duke
and public schools in north carolina
then later to duke university where'd
you go after duke i went to the united
states navy at officer candidate school
in the our paths didn't cross there but
they almost could have
what'd you do
i was in the naval security group
in uh in north africa and uh stationed
at portland morocco and the city of city
air morocco and then i came back and did
the same thing up at newport for two
years then what
then i went to new york to uh
to go into book publishing which is uh
then it was sort of accidental for
fashion now nowadays people prepare for
it a bit more i think i think there are
actually courses in this but there
certainly weren't in those days the
early 60s where did you work
i worked first
for the university of pennsylvania press
as a editor and
briefly
and then i went from there to charles
scribner's sons
and so i was at scrimmage for a very
long time doing the
history and biography and
science and things like that for them
for years and years and then after that
i was at
we were it was taken over by macmillan
and i left it to and then i took a
little bit of time off and then went to
uh
work to be the editorial director of
anchor books at double day
and then decided to write myself when i
saw all your your background and then i
looked in this random house random house
how does that fit i mean did you ever
work for random house no i didn't uh
well i think it's the
premiere of i would of course but it is
i think it's the
premier publishing house in america and
uh
then as gloria as i said my friend
gloria jones uh introduced me to uh
jamal loomis this brilliant editor at
random house who has been so helpful to
many many authors i mean i mean i'm in
good company with him he had his bill
stirring and then dan worsten and
any number of
famous people certainly and uh so i felt
like i was very good in very good
company indeed and so but that's how i
got to random house with through bob
loomis but you left out the third one of
my daddy
these three graces i suppose you're my
three muses and graces and liz of course
has been absolutely uh
i met her and uh
through shane alexander really in east
hampton and uh
she was up there renting a house in the
summer and uh so i was introduced to liz
and she invited me to come
stay in her guest house for two weeks
and i wound up staying for months and
months and uh in texas in texas in
austin hill overlooking austin texas and
so liz and i become great pals of course
everybody's pals with liz i mean you
know unless you're
not republicans but i mean all democrats
are pals would list
but in the uh random house uh
material they sent out uh which is
addressed to deer interviewer i guess
that's me yes all kinds of little
goodies in here
it says marshall to bruhl an intriguing
speaker and teller of tall tales in the
texas tradition
then apparent
texas governor ann richards and lady
bird johnson are both hosting dinners in
his honor
perrin will bring to light the lessons
today's politicians and indeed anyone
can learn from houston's life uh did
those parties happen they did indeed uh
when i first went there i i met mrs
johnson
uh i was staying in liz's little guest
house and and one morning i'd like to
work late at night and work all night
really and then sleep in the morning and
then get up and start again but uh
so one morning there was a knock on this
door this guest house where i was
staying and so i i just sort of groggly
said who is it and
and and i heard this wonderful boy soft
texas voice say who mr de bruyne are you
in there and i thought i've heard that
voice before but i wasn't sure who it
was and so i just went over the door and
i was really in my underwear and opened
the door and there's mrs johnson
who had come to
invite me to dinner she heard i was
there and so she'd come to invite me to
dinner she'd driven over there and she's
not far from liz and
so of course i ran back in and slammed
the door and put on some clothes and
came out and much embarrassed and she
brought this she hand delivered his
invitation and it was amusing she goes
you know i said yes i'd like to come and
i went back in and i read on the
invitation once she'd written that
please come to dinner and you can come
but only if you're going to make sam a
hero
she's a great she's a great fan of sam
houston's as was her husband of course
and that's his brother was named after
sam houston what about governor richards
governor richards has been uh wonderful
to me in my trips to texas and then she
had a dinner for me two weeks ago at the
governor's mansion and
very she's a wonderful person really i
think she's in the great tradition of
sam houston
as a matter of fact the night of the
dinner
at the governor's match in austin
it was the exact night that houston had
march 15th and it was the exact
night that he had spent all night
struggling with wrestling wrestling with
his conscience about whether what to do
about secession
and it was that very night that we were
there for dinner so ann richards asked
me to read that to
page or two about that in the so we went
into the library and read the where he
had come down that morning in the same
room and read this piece so it was very
moving for me to be able to do that in
the very house where houston had had
done this what do you mean by secession
well he had of course had opposed
secession and anything that threatened
to break up the union houston was
absolutely opposed to whether it was the
first year and this was in 1863.
now i'm sorry 1861.
and uh he uh earlier had gone through
the great battles with the nullifiers
with jackson and washington in the 1830s
but then later this this of course this
issue was not going to go away i mean
the whole idea of
the extension of slavery into the
territories so houston remember had
voted against the kansas nebraska bill
and and the
repealed missouri compromise
which made him anathema in texas to to
the slaveholders certainly was he a
slaveholder yes he was he was and uh but
he
was opposed to extension of slavery and
reopening of the slave trade and and
then indeed was convinced it was a dying
institution and was going to die out
and felt it should be allowed to die out
gradually because there were almost 4
million slaves in the south
but it was an issue that certainly was
not going to go away
so when he was
withdraw really recalled from the senate
in 1859 he went back to texas
and then was elected governor because
the common people adored this man of
course and uh they elected him governor
of the state but he still
would not go along with the rest of the
south in the secession movement and
even refusing to call a secessionist
convention until he was forced to do so
and then in march of uh 1861 just after
the lincoln inaugural when everybody was
succeeding of course and
he
wrote this famous letter to the people
of texas that he could not and would not
go along with this and so the next day
this was march 15th and the next day he
uh
was called to in front of the texas
legislature to swear a lot of allegiance
to the confederacy he refused to to
leave his office and go up to the just
wear the oath and of course he was
deposed from the governorship then and
went home to huntsville
by the way on the back of your
book
is this photograph
yes and you can't see it but down here
in little tiny letters is a photo by
lamont de bruyle that's my cousin in in
north carolina the photographer in
asheville north carolina and
he uh
is a brilliant photographer i think i
think he even managed to make me look
fairly respectable in that picture
so so you see this was a team effort my
sister locked me up in the house to
write the book and my cousin came down
to the that picture is at the at the
house in north carolina and to take my
picture so we try to keep things in the
family as much as possible did you make
sam houston a hero when you went to mrs
johnson's
yes indeed
indeed
he is a great hero he's uh
he's one of these great american figures
who who deserves to be known more than
he is actually people know
who he is i think but i think what
americans don't realize for the great
national figure he was
for example he was here in washington
for 13 years in the united states senate
and
and the two great issues of the time or
certainly the greatest issue of the time
of course was secession and the slavery
issue
and he uh well that's the great picture
of matthew brady by matthew brady of sam
who brady photographed him several times
and that's one of the pictures of him
here in the as a senator in here in
washington
and
but he uh
but he he absolutely was adamant in his
defense of the union that we could not
allow this great calamity to happen and
he warned the people of texas what would
happen to their young men and into their
to their farms and plantations in the
whole south for that matter if they
pursued this
with this folly of the of secession
and and lincoln of course offered this
in 50 000 troops into texas to keep it
in the union
and houston refused to do that because
it would it would just make it even more
bloodshed if he had done that he
wouldn't do it
but and i think that
puts him right up there with american
heroes to my estimation and the other
one of course was his uh
in defense of the american indians his
friends the native americans which he
every chance he got he stood up on the
floor of the congress or the texas
legislature on speeches around the
country to defend his his friends the
indians and the fact that the whites
should honor these treaties we'd made
with them of course we did not and we
all know what happened there who was his
first wife
his first wife was a woman a young woman
from gallatin tennessee named eliza
allen
and she was the
daughter of a prominent tennessee family
and houston was 36 years old she was 20.
and it was an arranged marriage
the family was very ambitious for their
daughter
remember he was
pretty much on the road perhaps being
president of the united states at that
point he was a young governor of
tennessee had already served in
the congress of the united states he was
andrew jackson's protege
and
and i think there was a very good chance
if this marriage hadn't derailed his
political career in tennessee that he
could have gone on instead of james k
polk it might very well have been sam
houston as president of the united
states and there were other great
tennesseans like john bell for example
who was speaker of the house of
representatives
uh
jackson surrounded himself with these
brilliant brilliant men all from this
from tennessee some of them born other
places but all living in tennessee of
course and
in my opinion what jackson was trying to
do was to replicate whether it happened
in virginia except in what was
considered the frontier of tennessee to
have something
what i refer to as the tennessee dynasty
the way the
virginia dynasty came about with all
those presidents how long was he married
to her he was married for 11 weeks
and
he married her in on january 29th in
1829.
january 22nd 1829 jackson had just been
inaugurated president was on his way to
washington to be inaugurated and houston
stayed behind to marry
in the nashville or in gallatin and uh
but the marriage collapsed almost
immediately and uh
then she left him in april of that year
what impact did that have on him well he
resigned the governorship he spent a
week or so drinking in the nashville inn
where he was living in nashville
tennessee and then wrote a eloquent
brilliant letter to the people of
tennessee resigning the office and then
moving to the west to rejoin his indian
friends in the arkansas territory which
is now oklahoma
and he spent the next three years
ultimately in and out of arkansas and
here in washington and drinking
married
the daughter of the niece of the
cherokee chief of latika as a matter of
fact that was his second wife uh tiana
rogers how do you meet her
he had met her earlier when they when
when they lived in tennessee east
tennessee before there were indian
removal to the west
and or that group had moved to the west
and he knew her father and her brothers
they were great friends of houston's
when he remember he had lived with the
indians once before as a teenager he'd
left to run away from home and live with
the cherokees
and
so then he just simply
picked up with him again when he moved
moved to the west
and then lived as as man and wife really
they'd live together as man and wife in
the near fort gibson and there's now
oklahoma how long were they married
it would have been almost three years
from 1829 to 1832. why did it end
he
uh left for texas he came here you know
there was a great scan another great
scandal uh when he beat up the
congressman stanberry from ohio who
libeled him on the floor of the house of
representatives and houston beat him up
on pennsylvania avenue
and crippled him really and then they
brought charges against him and houston
was arrested then tried before the house
of representatives
and it was then he landed that was then
he left you know jackson's famous
comment when you heard that houston had
done this he said he wished he had more
houston's to cudgel the brains of
congress
and the washington papers said well you
know the school of nashville has come to
washington you know this sort of
settling arguments beat people up on
pennsylvania haven't you was he right in
beating this man up well i think the man
he misjudged his adversaries i think
what when houston asked him to explain
himself when he had said that houston
had been involved in a fraud scheme a
fraudulent scheme to
provide rations for the indian removal
which was not true he was involved in
trying to get the bid yes but it wasn't
fraud
and so to ask him to explain himself and
this man hid behind the privilege of the
house and said he didn't even have to
answer questions about this you know
after he was a congressman and he didn't
have to respond to this man at all
so houston then ran into and then the
congressman started the music houston
was
perhaps after him and started carrying
two pistols
and indeed fired one of them in houston
on pennsylvania avenue but it didn't go
off he put it against his chest and fire
but it didn't go off while houston was
beating him with a stick and
then the great trial in the house of
representatives which
which became almost like uh the oliver
north hearings that kind of thing i mean
it was it just uh transfixed the country
the dispatchers went out everywhere and
all the papers were covering and then i
was registered finally when it was all
over he said somehow sam houston's trial
is completed and they were so sick of
the whole thing because it had gone on
for weeks what decision did they make
well he was guilty but but he the night
before he had been drinking with the
speaker of the house
who was a friend of his and james k polk
and daniel webster and various other
people were all his pals and they were
all drinking at the hotel here in
washington and then the next day houston
was it was just a minor reprimand
but then he was taken before just
a judge here in washington to find 500
which later jackson
remitted and pardoned houston and all
the time and also jackson bought him his
suit to wear to the to the to the
congress to be tried before the house
and
and put him up at the white house so it
was pretty what pretty much uh
i mean he had friends in high places
certainly and uh
but then the as i say jackson later
remitted the fine and pardoned him so he
didn't pay the 500 you say he left his
uh his wife would where did he leave her
you mean the the indian second wife she
stayed she stayed behind in the arkansas
territory near fort gibson and uh she
died not long after that actually and uh
at what age how was their difference in
age i don't uh it's hard to tell again
she was much younger
as somebody remarked once in fact i may
even remarket myself that he uh
that houston uh
loved to drink and run around with older
men but he always married young women
and i think that his all of his friends
were older than men male friends were
much older than me and mentors really
and then but he always was attracted to
young young very young women
and
and she uh interesting enough she's
buried in the officer circle at the fort
gibson national cemetery in the
just outs in fort gibson oklahoma she
was an indian she was an indian yes uh
mixed of course her fa her father was a
scotch scotch trader actually so she was
predominantly white actually they most
of those indian leaders were at that
time strangely enough and slave owners
too she owned some slaves actually
and
but she died
in 1836 about 1840 1837 or somewhere in
there and she but then they later they
moved her body to the officer's circle
in this cemetery about 1900. any
children by the first or second wife
no children by the first uh
again there are all these stories about
houston's indian sons and daughters and
i think there may be some truth to that
certainly i ran across some letters in
the research
from indian boys in indian school in
pennsylvania for example that were
addressing him dear father now of course
that was an indian honorific too when
they would write letters they would say
dear father and you know to the
president or the president of texas or
whatever so it's hard to tell if these
were actually sam's
sons there's there's every chance that
they were of course because he
had been around quite a bit by that time
you know third wife third wife
margaret moffat lee and alabama bell
from marion alabama
and when houston was wounded at the
battle of san jacinto and was taken to
new orleans for medical treatment
and he arrived uh this very dramatic
entrance as he arrived in new orleans on
the steamboat
and uh this young girl she was 17 then
how old was he
he was 40 well then he was 43
and uh
so she um she was on the pier in new
orleans she was visiting visiting family
in new orleans and she saw him and and
was so was taken with him three years
later then met him and married him in
alabama and when he was visiting there
and uh but he was 46 and and she was 20.
kind of a marriage was it well it was a
very happy one of course i sat down once
with a calculator figured out actually
how much time they spent together and it
wasn't a whole hell of a lot in the
years they were married because he would
be in washington sometimes as much as 10
months out of the year
then you when you put in the travel time
to texas in those days and back he
didn't see her very often
but it was obviously a great love match
you read their letters i mean they're
hundreds of letters and um and they had
these eight children
the youngest of whom was only two when
houston died at age 70
and temple lee houston
but
she was clearly in love with her husband
she was a very beautiful young woman
really and a very religious extremely
religious baptist and certainly a
teetotaler there's a great story when
margaret had some
breast tumor and um
she needed to be operated on of course
there was no anesthetic or anything
those days and so they so that asheville
smith sam's great friend who the doctor
in texas was going to operate on to take
this remove this tumor
and
she wouldn't even take any whiskey
because it was just so against her
religion so she literally bit down on a
bullet while they removed this thing so
she was a woman of some strength clearly
and uh the material that tells us about
your book they say that the the biggest
new thing in here are 5 000 new letters
there was a great um
collection andrew andrew jackson houston
one of houston's sons
became the family historian really and
he uh kept the car sam's correspondence
and and all of the letters and well i
and so these things are in the texas
state archives this great collection of
letters
and
it has not had not been systematically
gone through until i actually did it and
and there was extraordinary things in
there i mean for example i ran across
james bonham's letter offering his
services to the republic of texas the
original letter is in this file
houston's uh
his own personal correspondence of
course but what i found most interesting
were letters to him from people
often often not friendly at all he had
quite a few enemies of course and
but there was one letter in particular
that was so touching i think gives you
some idea of the humanity of this great
man
there was a letter from a woman from
tennessee
and she was asking about her son who was
missing
and she hadn't heard from him in months
and months he had gone to fight for the
texans and the revolution and in the
bottom of the letter
houston had written i learned to
recognize his handwriting from a hundred
paces after i read so much of it and at
the bottom of the letter in his
unmistakable handwriting he'd written an
answer this kindly because he had had
his
men check on this and her boy who was
about 17 had been killed at goliad in
that terrible massacre so then houston
really heard this very gentle letter
almost like the letter lincoln wrote to
the woman who's lost so many sons
and
so there were a lot of things like that
and just day after day i would go
through this and
and read these extraordinary documents
and uh
and often they were also very funny i
mean he could be he was you know he was
a great wit he was a great storyteller
and
and uh
and used all of these wonderful southern
southern expressions and things which i
i loved when he said to asheville smith
he was going to enter the run for
governor of texas and he said you know
we've got to be up and up and doing to
the last minute he said remember it's
the long pole that gets the persimmon
and i had i must say when i put that in
my manuscript
one of the coffee editors had no idea
what that meant so i had to explain what
persimmons were and you had to use a
pole to get them down
such things as that
but i enjoyed those a little lot of that
anyway and again back to this publicity
letter
signed by becky simpson the senior
publicist at randolph that's my good
friend indeed we're good friends now
certainly but this paragraph intrigued
me i wanted to ask you about it debruil
also points to many of america's most
influential figures in the media
and in politics from walter cronkite dan
rather and liz smith to ross perot and
george bush who are all texans and
living proofs that the bold spirit for
which sam houston fame was famous lives
on didn't mention lennon johnson
well they should well well these are
people who are live i think is that
right i'm surprised i'm george bush
walter cronkite dan rather lists me i
guess so i'm letting becky off here
is there something special about texas
i think there is there is this uh
liz and i've talked about this at great
lengths i talked to mrs johnson and and
ann and all these people there is
something special i think it's the the
enormous amount of room that people have
that that's why they're expansive they
you look out and you see this great sky
and planes and prairies and things and
people are otherwise i think there's
more expansive
but i think also sam left this heritage
he was this
he became the embodiment of texas and i
think people have tried to live up to
that too because he was here in
washington and for so long 13 years and
people when they thought of of texas
they are saying
with sam houston they were they were so
inextricably bound i think the two ideas
of sam houston and texas
so that he lived here at willard's hotel
and when he left i mean
it's the same spot but it's the same
same place yeah and uh so he lived there
for years and years and uh
it's in the i found the interesting
thing he kept six canaries in the room
and
things i don't know
and
you put cards around the road my bedtime
is six it's nine o'clock and i expect
everyone to be out of the room by nine
o'clock when he had company or this kind
of thing but he was a little eccentric
but then when he left it took three days
for people to come by and tell him
goodbye i think half of washington came
by to tell him goodbye and they realized
how they were going to much they were
going to miss this great man
and and i think this image of texas he
was largely responsible for that and
people then texans of course have been
busily living up to it ever since you
know the flamboyance and the
and it's also but i think the great
integrity too
and also all these great texans they
listen to people they really liked it
they love stories they love to tell
stories but mainly to listen to stories
you call him a hero and a great man and
i just want to relate that to the day
you your your book is full of stories of
his serious drinking problems maybe
drugs opium beast yes indeed married
three times all the very young women and
a couple one case at least he left her
slave home owner owned slaves of his own
yes
uh i think you know where i'm going with
this i see yes
i don't know how i'm gonna get myself
out of this corner but go ahead well
so often when we look back at the past
we see the same connections kind of the
same kind of things illegitimate
children drinking problems uh slave
owners how do we justify calling those
folks heroes today well i think
you know
i'm not going to use this thing about
you know judging people from the time
because there were many people of that
time who were certainly abolitionists
and uh so i think we can judge people by
their times
indeed but houston's greatness lay into
two
two things one was this uh
defense of the union the fact that we
must not
uh secede we must not allow this
terrible war to happen and he warned
about this all for years and years of
course there was no it happened happens
as we all know
the other one
was the fact that we really must honor
our commitments to the to the indians
the native americans and and do do
what's right by these people and those
are the two great
guiding lights it seems to me in his
life that
that really made him a great man
now the slavery issue obviously
he even charles sumner the abolitionist
senator from massachusetts
said that he and sam were
in agreement about this or they they
found a lot to agree on they liked each
other actually
and uh
so i felt that houston if people if
there'd been more southerners like sam
houston maybe we could have headed off
the civil war unlikely but
because i think it was one of those
things that had to play itself out
it was just we were just headed toward
that cliff or going over that waterfall
there was not much we could do to avert
that as seeds had been sown in the 18th
century
to have this terrible war
and uh and we had that the slaves simply
had to be freed i mean there was no way
out of that it had to be done
let me ask you though about in history
were there any of them any of these
great historical figures that said i
believe so strongly in the abolition of
slavery that i'm going to let my slaves
go free it seems like almost all of them
said
well when i die i'll let them free
the only one of the founding fathers who
freed the slaves was george washington
and
and he did free several of them and then
the others were tied in with his wife's
estate but then they were to be freed
when she died but he was the only one
who did really the story there's a great
story about thomas jefferson he freed
his slaves of course that's not true he
had 200 i think it was 67 or 87 slaves
when he died
and he freed five of those those men
uh or maybe women but but only five out
of this enormous number of people that
he had at montcello
and
the other problem of course with that
freeing slaves in those days was that
they had nowhere to go because in
virginia had the slave codes of course
the free slaves could not live in
virginia texas had that except houston
would not enforce it when he was
president of texas and governor of texas
he wouldn't enforce that law whether
they passed this terrible law that
even freed slaves either had to leave
the state or else go back into bondage
and he didn't but he didn't enforce that
he put it off you see unfortunately
how has the reaction in your opinion
been to your book life of sam history
very oh it's been very good indeed yeah
any surprises along the way
uh
well i think
i'm always surprised by some of the the
provincialism perhaps i i uh
that uh people don't realize he was a
great national figure i think that's the
thing that surprises me to some degree
but i've been trying to write that one
one amusing thing happened and well
there are many many amusing things i
remember was sitting at a dinner party
with this for a very long time you know
you can have a conversation with
somebody and you're talking about two
entirely different things but it works
you know they say something and you say
something and you think that you're in
total consonance and agreement and
finally after about 15 minutes this
woman at the dinner party turned to me
and said
have you ever met his daughter angelica
you must talk to her
and i realized she of course was talking
about the great film director
and so those were surprises like that
you see but uh i think that uh yes but
often no generally not i think it's it's
uh it's been gratifying the number of of
uh fans i guess to use this word that
this man has in this country and and
people realize what an extraordinary man
he was kind of as a recap and i wrote
him down the beginning and you can fill
in the blanks here um
he ran for congress first in 1823 in
tennessee in tennessee how many terms
did he spend in congress two terms
and then jackson asked him to come home
and run for governor of the state which
he and he won he won indeed governor of
the state of tennessee yes
for how long
he served one term and then in the
middle this marriage fell apart in the
as the election was beginning for the
second term and he
fled he fled to arkansas yes how long
was he in arkansas three years
and then where then to texas
in 1832 december of 18th the battle of
san jacinto that you write about was in
1836 yes april 21st coming up in two
days yes and in 1836 um
he was elected president of the texas
president of texas what did that mean
being president well it was a separate
nation the republic of texas so he was
the first elected president of texas and
then then in uh three years he was
elected to the second term but he lost
out in the middle well no in the middle
well no they couldn't succeed themselves
you see i said so then he but he ran for
the texas congress and served in the
congress in that time you see so he he
didn't go away at all he was in the
congress again
uh standing up every chance he got to
get them to ratify the treaties with the
with the indians and give them their
land united states annexed texas in 1845
yes
he was elected by the state legislature
in 1847 to the united states senator
1846 i'm sorry
actually took well no never mind my
figures wrong um how long did you say he
spent 13 years there he spent two terms
yeah he was into the second uh
he was in this the uh at first he was
re-elected and then uh he spent 13 years
in the senate yeah 46-59 yeah and then
he but this but they because of his vote
against the kansas nebraska bills he had
just been re-elected
so he just was determined to serve out
that term
even though they wanted him to come home
and he was
being vilified by so many people in
texas for this vote against the kansas
nebraska but he stayed in washington in
the beginning of your book you have a
little saying of sam houston's and i'll
show the audience but i'll read it first
i haven't i have sought not to live in
vain yes where did that come from and
why did you choose that i um
he
uh
had been asked or people were forever uh
talking about doing biographies of
houston and uh
so he's uh in a letter to this a
prospective biographer he said you know
it's in your idea of writing a book
about me interests me and i have not
sought to live in vain and i think as i
said also an introduction i think the
biography would be you know would be
looked upon with interest
and
so i think that it certainly uh in my to
my way of thinking it was and i just
thought that
that was a sort of wonderful uh epigram
for him you know i have not sought to
live in vain and then and as i've said
in speeches around the country of this
thing that then he did not he certainly
did not live in vain you have another
book in you well there's a lot of talk
about andrew jackson and i
any researcher historian or biographer
when you work on something like this you
the great
problem of course with digressions you
know you come across somebody or
something and you start reading and
reading and reading and jackson was the
man and i become so almost besotted by
jackson i found him to be this
fascinating person so perhaps that might
be the next thing
this is uh what the book looks like it's
the sword of san jacinto and a life of
the life of sam houston by marshall de
bruyne thank you very much for joining
us thank you very much
marshall de bruyne is the author of
sword of san jacinto a life of sam
houston a biography of the once
president of texas and u.s senator
to read a transcript of this interview
visit the book notes website at
booknotes.org
every weekend book tv brings you an
encore